pump the music I know how to do this I
got spat on this school I was big I was
black I was gay the day that happened I
had to break to her my breakthrough was
once I stood up everyone else seemed
like oh I'm precious and I'm part of the
legendary ballroom scene of New York
City so ballroom was like a huge safe
haven for people of LGBTQ I experienced
when I seem that the commentators were
like the center of attention at a ball I
was like oh this needs to be my job
growing up in the ballroom you'd be
surprised at how many people are gonna
appreciate you for being you are and
gender non-binary for me I don't feel
like I have to be like a boy or I don't
feel like I have to be a girl stick of
water has known the minutes and moves
this orange is sending me miss honey
what can make you feel better about
yourself for me that was putting on
makeup it gives me that touch of
femininity it gives me like the deepness
of masculinity liking my eyebrows that
speaks for itself it's just like oh yeah
big [ __ ] energy it's me I would be
known for someone who uplifted people
across the world and for me that was
getting none of my I can get on the mic
and I can give you something you can
feel and then ballroom help me with that
trust me
all my people had to fight but without a
fight there wouldn't have been no
success hi my name is precious let me
get this off my chest
you